ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY IT'S TUESDAY
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS.
ON OUR AGENDA TODAY WE'LL START
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO SJ ARE
[inaudible]
TWENTY NINE JAPAN.
WE WILL BE A OPERATING AS
SUBCOMMITTEE WE DON'T QUITE GET
HAVE A QUORUM OF PLEASE OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
STR TWENTY NINE CALLS UPON THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS TO ISSUE
A FORMAL APOLOGY TO ALL
IMMIGRANT DETAINEES WHO HAVE
BEEN FORCIBLY SEPARATED FROM THE
PARENTS.
THE RESULT OF OUR BORDER
POLICIES FOLLOWING THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER ISSUED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
A MEMO BY THE TOURNEY GENERAL
JEFF SESSIONS IN APRIL THIS YEAR
THE UNITED STATES HAS
INSTITUTED.
IT'S CALLED A ZERO TOLERANCE
POLICY REGARD TO IMMIGRANT
VIOLATIONS.
HOWEVER THIS AND PRESENT IN
HUMANE POLICY HAS LED DIRECTLY
LEAD TO THE FORCIBLE SEPARATION
OF OVER. TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
IMMIGRANT INFANTS AND CHILDREN
OR FROM THEIR PARENTS TO REMAIN
IN CUSTODY WHILE AWAITING TRIAL.
WELL SUPPORTERS OF THE POLICY OF
CLAIM THAT'S MERELY ENFORCEMENT
OF EXISTING LAW LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT UNITED NATIONS HUMAN
RIGHTS OFFICE.
THE HIGH COMMISSIONER HAS STATED
THAT FAMILY SEPARATION
THEMSELVES SERIOUS VIOLATIONS OF
THE RIGHTS OF THE CHILD.
ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT THE
PRESIDENT AMERICAN CAN BE
PEDIATRICS HAS PUBLICLY STATED
THAT THIS THAT THIS IS
GOVERNMENT SANCTIONED CHILD
ABUSE.
SO EVEN THOUGH THE UNITED STATES
IS THE ONLY MEMBER STATE NOT TO
HAVE RATIFIED THE CONVENTION THE
RIGHTS OF THE CHILD THE UNITED
NATIONS HAS STATED THAT SINCE WE
SIGNED.
THAT SINCE WE TIED AN
INTERNATIONAL COURT WE DO HAVE
SOME LEGAL OBLIGATIONS TO
CHILDREN A CUSTODY.
ASIDE FROM THE INHERENT CRUELTY
OF SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM
THEIR FAMILIES THERE'S ALSO
CONSIDERABLE RESEARCH SHOWING
THEIR SIGNIFICANT PROLONGED
HEALTH RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
HIGH LEVELS OF STRESS AND
CHILDHOOD.
IF YOU ARE TWENTY NINE FIRST
SEEKS TO HIGHLIGHT THE
OVERWHELMING CONSENSUS AMONG
RESEARCHERS THAT PROLONGED
EXPOSURE TO TOXIC STRESS FX
SHORT AND LONG TERM HEALTH.
WHILE MOST OF US ARE LIKELY
WHERE THE POTENTIAL MENTAL
HEALTH EFFECTS SUCH AS
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
THERE ALSO LONG TERM SERIOUS
PHYSICAL HARMS ASSOCIATED WITH
EXCESSIVE CHILDHOOD STRESS IN
FACT ON GOINGS AND EXPOSURE TO
STRESS CAN ACTUALLY DISRUPT THE
FORMATION OF THE CHILD'S BRAIN
ARCHITECTURE.
AND CAN ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
LATER DEVELOPMENT OF CHRONIC
CONDITIONS SUCH AS
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE.
SECOND S. YOU ARE TWENTY NINE
CALLS UPON THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS TO FORMALLY APOLOGIZE
NOT ONLY FOR THE SEPARATION
FAMILIES BUT ALSO FOR TO PROLONG
INCREASED HEALTH RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE IMAGE
UNIMAGINABLE STRESS.
EXPERIENCED BY THOSE WHO CAN
SEPARATE FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
NOW THE UNITED STATES HAS BEEN A
LEADER AND SETTING STANDARDS FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS AND THE WORLD AND
THAT WE HAVE --
ALWAYS SAID THAT WE ARE
EXCEPTIONAL IN OUR OUR
DIPLOMATIC RELATIONS IN TERMS OF
UPHOLDING THIS HIGHER STANDARD
IN FACT BECAUSE OF THAT --
THE UNITED STATES ALSO I ISSUED
FORMAL APOLOGIES FOR OUR PAST --
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS
CERTAINLY WE ARE NOT PERFECT BUT
WE RECOGNIZE OUR HEIRS --
AT SOME OF THE EXAMPLES INCLUDE
--
RONALD REAGAN'S THAT ARE
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT APOLOGY
FOR THE INTERNMENT OF JAPANESE
CITIZENS DURING WORLD WAR.
TWO AND THE CLINTON'S
ADMINISTRATION'S NINETEEN NINETY
SOME APOLOGY FOR THAT TUSKEGEE
EXPERIMENTS CONDUCTED.
IN THE NINETEEN FORTIES THROUGH
THE SEVENTIES.
NOW WHILE THESE APOLOGIES I CAME
DECADES AFTER VIOLATIONS TAKING
PLACE THERE'S NO REASON FOR US
TO HAVE TO WAIT.
WHY SHOULD WE WAIT TO APOLOGIZE
TO CHILDREN WHO'VE BEEN FORCIBLY
REMOVED FROM THEIR FAMILIES?
WE NOTE WE MADE A MISTAKE AND
THIS IS WRONG.
SO WHAT THAT YOU ARE TWENTY NINE
WE ASK CONGRESS APOLOGIZE NOW
FOR THE HARMS THOSE PRET BOTH
PRESENT AN ON GOING BECAUSE BY.
OUR ADMINISTRATION'S POLICY OF
SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM THEIR
FAMILIES AT THE BORDER I SPECT
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I
ALSO HAVE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ FROM
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITNESS PLEASE YOUR MORNING
ARMCHAIR MEMBERS AKIS FOR
SCIENCES WHICH I LOVE THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS STRONGLY SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION.
ARE AS THE SENATOR HAS INDICATED
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
UNFORTUNATELY THAT OUR COUNTRY
HAS CAUSED HARM TO FOLKS I'VE
SPECIFICALLY IMMIGRANTS OFFERED
THAT REASON YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ASK CONGRESS TO APOLOGIZE.
OP FROM OUR POINT OF VIEW IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN SEPARATED OUGHT NOT JUST
NOW BUT IN OUR PAST AND THAT
THIS IS A DARK TIME FROM OUR
POINT OF VIEW ARE. FOR THE
UNITED STATES AS YOU KNOW THERE
WAS SEVERAL CASE WE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL CENTERS WHERE THAT HOW
THE INFLUENCE ARMS THAT WERE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILIES UP
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED THEIR THEIR
MOTHERS OR FATHERS WHATEVER THEY
TRAVELED.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
CHEN MEMBERS ON THE HAND OTHER
ON WHAT THE WHITE IMMIGRANT
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
THING NONE OF RING BACK THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IT'S IN AND WE WILL TAKE THIS UP
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FASTER.
THINK THIS ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
[inaudible]
SIXTEEN NINETEEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
AND ONE IN THREE WOMEN AND ONE
AND SIX MEN.
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL VIOLENCE AT
SOME POINT IN THEIR LIVES.
MANY SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVORS
SUFFER FROM PHYSICAL INJURIES
AND MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
THAT PREVENT THEM FROM REGAINING
STABILITY IN THEIR LIVES FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
THERE IS ALSO A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL CONCEPTS OR SEXUAL
ASSAULT DUE TO INCREASED
HEALTHCARE NEEDS LOST WAGES AND
LEGAL EXPENSES.
CURRENT LAW ONLY PROVIDES A LINK
YEAR STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
CIVIL CLAIMSBASED ON SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND TO LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE FIRST A CASE OF CHILDHOOD
SEX PARA OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ABUSE.
AND THE SECOND A CASE AGAINST
THE DEFENDANT WHO'S BEEN
CONVICTED OF A SPECIFIED SERIOUS
FELONY SUCH AS RAPE.
AND ALL OF IN ALL OTHER CASES OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT PLAINTIFFS MUST
COMMENCE A CIVIL ACTION WITHIN
TWO YEARS.
OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THIS TIME FRAME IS NOT REALISTIC
FOR MANY SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS WHO ARE RECOVERING
FROM THE PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL
TRAUMA OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT.
UNDER THIS BILL PLAINTIFFS WOULD
HAVE TEN YEARS FROM THE DATE OF
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT OR THREE
YEARS FROM THE DATE OF DISCOVERY
OF AN ILLNESS OR INJURY THAT
RESULTED FROM THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
WHICHEVER IS LATER.
BY DOING SO AB SIXTEEN NINETEEN
RECOGNIZES THE SERIOUSNESS OF
ALL FORMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT IN
THE ARDUOUS RECOVERY PROCESS
THAT ENSUES AFTERWARDS.
WITH ME TODAY IS CHECK A LEAN
WINTERS HALL.
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAMINERS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE B..
SIX THANK YOU BEFORE THAT
WITNESSES THAT THIS W. OR
CULTURAL PLEASE STONE HERE.
CUNNINGHAM IT CHAO.
CHIU HOLDEN KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
REYES.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
THE FIRST WITNESS WITH GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I'M JACQUELINE WINNERS HALL I AM
A SEXUAL ASSAULT FORENSIC
NURSING EXAMINER AND I AM THE
SAFE TEAM COORDINATOR IN BUTTE
COUNTY.
MOSS ON THE EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR CAL SAFE.
HOW SAFE IS PROUD TO SPONSOR ï„
SIXTEEN NINETEEN WE'VE MADE
GREAT STRIDES IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS ADDRESSING
SEXUAL ASSAULT SUPPORTING
SURVIVORS?
THIS IS THE NEXT GOOD STEP THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS HAS BEEN
ELIMINATED FOR CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
AND WE HAVE DEVELOPED A SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVOR RIGHTS CARDS
NOW -- THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVOR RIGHTS
CARDS ARE MANDATED BY ALL
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
EVERYONE THAT PRESENTS WITH A
COMPLAINT OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
WHETHER THEY WANT TO REPORT OR
NOT [inaudible]
WITHIN MINUTES [inaudible]
RIGHTS CARD.
IS MANDATED THAT WE INFORM THE
PATIENT.
THAT.
IF SHOULD THEY HAVE EVIDENCE
COLLECTED IT WILL BE SENT TO A
LAB FOR PROCESSING WITHIN TWENTY
DAYS.
IT ALSO STATES THAT THE LAB HAS
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. TO PROCESS
THE EVIDENCE WHICH MEANS.
THE STATUTE PERSONAL CIVIL
REMEDY HAS RUN OUT BEFORE THE
PATIENT IS.
EVEN KNOWS THE RESULTS OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE COLLECTED
FROM THEIR OWN BODY --
MOST PATIENTS DON'T EVEN REAL
AYE.
AYE MINURSO THERE MY PATIENTS
THEIR SURVIVORS IN AND VICTIMS
SO.
FORGIVE ME WHEN I SAY PATIENT UP
MAYES MOST PATIENTS AREN'T EVEN
AWARE OF THE AVAILABILITY OF
CIVIL REMEDIES FOR THE HAVE LONG
LASTING IN LIFE TIME.
A FAX OF SEXUAL ASSAULTS AND
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THE
AVERAGE SEXUAL ASSAULT COSTS
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER VICTIM.
OVER A LIFETIME THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SMOKE MORE LIKELY TO
DRINK MORE LIKELY TO BE OBESE
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE LIFETIME
MEDICAL PROBLEMS.
AND AYE INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
LESS LIKELY TO WEAR SEAT BELTS
IT'S A REALLY INTERESTING STUDY
--
THESE PATIENTS NEED.
SUPPORT OVER A LIFETIME TWO
YEARS.
ISN'T EVEN ENOUGH TIME FOR A
CRIMINAL TRIAL TO MAKE ITS WAY
THROUGH BEFORE THEY CAN DO IT
PATIENTS ARE.
SURVIVORS DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY MOST DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO EVEN CONSIDER A
CIVIL TRIAL WHILE THEY'RE
FOCUSING.
ON SURVIVING THROUGH A CRIMINAL
TRIAL AND JUST RECOVERING.
I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU IF YOU'LL
INDULGE ME FOR A MINUTE OF
PATIENT THAT I RECENTLY HAD
ABOUT THIRTY MORE SECONDS UP.
PERFECTLY ILLUSTRATED THIS YOU
CAME IN.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY I* ATTEMPTED
TO HARM HERSELF AND SHE ASKED
FOR ME AND WORK IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT BUT I WENT DOWN THERE
ANYWAY.
SHOULD BANDAGED ARMS TEAR
STAINED FACE I DIDN'T RECOGNIZE
HER BUT I HAD DONE HER EXAMINED
EARLY.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND HER
CASE JUST GOT CONTINUED AGAIN.
AND SHE COULDN'T TAKE IT
ANYMORE.
SO SHE TRIED TO KILL HERSELF SHE
HAS DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL.
SHE'S BARELY WORKING A JOB.
AND HER CIVIL REMEDY IS.
ALREADY STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
HAS RUN OUT TO SO IMPORTANT.
FOR SURVIVORS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
A LITTLE MORE TIME [inaudible]
TO GETS MORE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
YOU COULD JUST GIVE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION.
LEE OF ARROWS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TO ON CAP KHIMKI
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS OUR OPPOSITION.
SING NONE BRING A BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
THREATS.
AND SOON YOU'LL HAVE TO GIVE --
AND YOU'LL HAVE.
TO IF THIS IS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR YOU'LL HAVE TO HAVE NEW
CARDS DONE --
IN ADDITION WE HAVE A SIMILAR
BILL EXTENDING THE SUCH
LIMITATIONS WHEN IT'S EMPLOYMENT
--
SEXUAL HARASSMENT SO AFTER TO IT
AFTER THIS YEAR YOUR YOU WILL
NEED NEW CARS BUT I WOULD LIKE
ONE BEFORE YOU LEAVE ALSO.
HANK IS AND I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THINKING.
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS COMMON
[inaudible]
RIGHT SING NONE SOME MEMORY
MIKLOS I'D JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM I'M LOOKING
FOR A MOTION THE MOTION WOULD BE
THAT.
THANK YOU THE MOTIONS THAT WE
CONCUR DID YOU HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU.
CALDERON PLEASE.
STONE AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU.
HOLDEN.
KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES
[inaudible]
REYES I THANK YOU THAT BILL IS
OUT WE HAVE CONCURRED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU YOU AT THE
COMMOTION ON SJ ARE TWENTY NINE
SENATOR CABINET EARLIER.
THANK YOU THAT MOTION AS IS THAT
IT'S YOUR TWENTY NINE BE
ADOPTED.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
CHAU.
CHAU I CHIU HOLDEN.
KALRA KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES [inaudible]
REYES I THAT.
RESOLUTION IS OUR CALL IT NEEDS
TO MORE VOTES.
SO IF YOU CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS
.
BUT I'M GOING.
TO STR TWENTY NINE IS ON CALL IN
A LIFT THE COLONIST HERE UNITE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHIU HOLDEN KALRA [inaudible]
CALLER I STILL LEAVES ONE MORE
VOTES WILL REPLACE THE CALL.
A. B. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SIXTEEN
NINETEEN IS OUT BUT YOU CAN CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA AYE.
IF YOU I'M GONNA GO BACK TO S.
AIR TWENTY NINE IBM TO EMIT A
LIFT THE CALL COLLAPSE MEMBERS
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
SO CALLED OLD AGE AIR
[inaudible]
TWENTY NINE HOLDEN I I GIVE THAT
IS OUT.
AND THEN ADD ONS TO AB SIXTEEN
NINETEEN BERMAN CALL THAT'S A
MEMBER HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
AND WE ARE DONE THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH WE ARE ADJOURNED